okay good morning everybody
um welcome to this meeting with the
public engagement board
um quite a lot of items on the agenda to
get through
um most notably obviously at the
10-point plan update so we will
make a start straight away um i'm not
aware of any apologies that have come
through um but if if there are please do
just
um just make those known now if that's
okay
uh non-received chair okay thank you
um and any declarations of interest
in any of the items on the agenda from
anybody
no okay um and then
the third item on the agenda is the
minutes of the meeting held on
the 2nd of november are people
able to confirm that those are an
accurate record
ken okay great thank you
um which brings us through then to
the um update on the current coverage
situation
in trafford so um eleanor do you want to
um give us that update if that's okay
please
yes so um we're we're
now at a point where it looks like our
rates are leveling off
they're not across the whole greater
manchester rates are now coming down i
was coming down
slightly more slowly than some of the
others but we started from a lower base
so
uh we're currently the second lowest in
greater manchester which um but our
rates are still
nearly 400 per hundred thousand we're at
376 per hundred thousand
as of the week ending the 11th of
november
um and our rates for our people age 60
plus
um are still high so there are
328 100 000 um
where we're the fourth lowest in greater
manchester so again it's
it's that population that we're most
concerned about really
about how we try and get the popul the
rates down in that population
we can only do that by the rates coming
down in the whole
population um because uh most people
aged over 60 obviously are
living in uh living normal lives with
everybody else
um and they're subject to the same risks
as
as everybody else in the population uh
as people will know the lockdown started
on the 6th of
november and so we are
now just i would say over this next week
we'll start seeing the impact of the
lockdown because of the incubation
periods for the disease
that you you don't see that that impact
straight away
we should start seeing that impact and
hopefully we will get
our rates down a lot lower the i know
this chief medical officer is hoping
that
by the end of the lockdown nationally
we'll be at an r of about
0.8 but an hour of 0.8 needs also to be
um also in a situation where we don't
have very many cases
so that we can quickly get on top of
outbreaks as they occur
so um so that's i think the main thing
around the current situation
in terms of rates and numbers um
again i would really stress to people we
need to take full advantage of this
lockdown and really change our behavior
over the next two weeks get those
numbers right down
so that we've got any chance of coming
out of it and
being able to get anything like back to
a normal life
um two two pieces of good news one is
that
um the first vaccine has uh has been
showing very positive results in trials
um and uh it's likely that we'll be able
to start vaccinating
um starting with people in care homes
and
um in um housebound people
um and that is likely to be starting
there may be a little bit of vaccination
before christmas it's likely to be
starting in january
um there's another vaccine that's coming
on that if it
succeeds then there's a chance that
we'll get the whole population
vaccinated
um in the spring by the spring but um
if not it'll probably be early summer
but we will at least be able to get our
most vulnerable populations vaccinated
more quickly so that is fantastic news
and the other piece of good news is that
the um the mass
testing um that they're trialling in
liverpool
is um that we will be able to get access
to some of those tests in
trafford and we're just currently
putting clients together of how we'd use
those
it's not it's not quite as
straightforward as
as we might want in that you do need to
get the have people going to a testing
center for this
rather than being able to give it to
people in their homes to test before
they
decide whether to go to work but um
we'll bring you more about that next
um next time and also with we're um
invest in the council is investing in
more community engagement work
which we'll pick up in the ten point
plan so i think that's the summary
eleanor um so as always quite a
fast moving picture but are there any um
questions or comments from eleanor
from anything she's just said that um
either pop in the chat if you'd like to
come in or raise the
razor handy
[Music]
now okay we will um move straight on
then to the
to the 10-point plan and look at some of
the um
specific areas in in detail so um 5a
is the mass testing donna were you going
to give us an update on this please
thank you chair yes and as elena has
mentioned and and we're really lucky
we've got uh martin on the call as well
chair so he may want to um add some
uh additional information as he's then
got the gm perspective which is really
helpful
um eleanor was in a call with matt
hancock on friday
and we received some further details
about the availability of um
a new swabbing technique actually to
support mass testing
and that swab is is quite an interesting
one because the results come back much
quicker
than the traditional one which usually
takes between 48 to 72 hours
and so we've just been looking at the
standard operating processes
and there's lots of details to work
through not least of which workforce
where the sites would be how we do the
invitations and all those processes
i think as elena pointed out we'd like
to make sure that that
the mass testing offer focuses on our
most vulnerable and those people who are
at higher risk
and particularly if we have any cohorts
or geographical areas where we feel mass
testing may need to take place
so at the moment chair um just just a
point this is for asymptomatic testing
rather than symptomatic testing and so
at the moment we're just starting to
pull together all the details
and some new training videos come out
and we're looking again at which
staff we can train up to carry that
procedure
um could i just give you an update on
the other other testing
areas of work um as part of this
yeah yeah so um as you'll all be aware
um
we do offer symptomatic testing um to
our trafford residents
we have seen a slight reduction in the
numbers i think that might be part of
the lockdown and people aren't going out
as much and
and obviously not requiring the need for
testing but the testing sites are still
up and running
in trafford and well attended um
we've also started to introduce now a
new measure for our staff who visit
care homes so they'll have routine
regular testing so
we're preventing any um any spread the
virus in that way so that would be a
really strong opportunity for that
um our care homes continue into doing
huge amounts of testing
um for their staff and residents and
finally um
we were informed about um some antibody
testing
which at the moment is available to um
all
staff who are employed in adult social
care so we have got that message out
a little bit of a warning around
antibody testing because it is really
for
prevalence data rather than any clinical
value
so we do strongly emphasize that even
though you might have antibodies
that shouldn't change your clinical
practice or shouldn't change
you know any of the infection control
measures you put into place
and so we have sent that information out
to our staff
thank you thanks donna are there any
questions or comments for donna on
testing
[Music]
no um neither sorry
there is one from dorothy evans oh sorry
dorothy come in
[Music]
so with regards to the antibody testing
um
for staff how do they access that
um there is a there is a website and
that i can send to you uh dorothy
um and it's people in adult page adult
social care roles
and it's um it's literally you go into
the website you book the test
it's a fingerprint test um and then you
send the results
then you send the test back and you get
the results that way so i can send you
details of how to access that if you're
interested
yes great thank you
thank you um anybody else want to
call i can't see
any hands or anything in the chat so
we will move on to um mass vaccination
in trafford
um rebecca potentially um
more promising news
hi everybody can you see and hear me
yep thank you and for those that don't
know me i'm rebecca domain
i'm an associate director of
commissioning at trafford ccg
um and um taking an active role in the
um rollout of the vaccination program
covered vaccination programme for
trafford
and so invited me to give you um a brief
update
um in terms of mass vaccination so
that's the entire kind of population
um program and that is very much at the
moment being led
at a gm level and about a month or so
ago we were asked to
nominate a couple sites for mass
population vaccination in traffic
um but the the conversation now seems to
be moving um away from that and into a
more of a gm
led conversation and gm identified sites
so i'll provide a further update on that
when we get some more clarity
um what i'd like to do today is just
update on the
um priority population which um ellen
had briefly touched on before
so um on monday of last week um the
national team
issued a draft specification
for delivery of vaccinations through
general practice
so that came out on monday and the ask
for
the general practice delivery is for the
groupings primary care network level to
be identified so i'm sure most of you
know we've got
five primary care networks in trafford
and we've been asked to nominate
designated sites within the five
networks to deliver the vaccinations
through general practice for the
high-risk groups
and as ellen mentioned at the moment the
priority is is over 80s
residents of care homes and staff of
care homes
um and then moving on to over 50s at
high risk
and primary care staff but at the moment
what we understand is it's very much
going to be about the
care home residents housebound residents
and as i say the
over 80s so as elena mentioned the ask
is to be prepared
for delivery of that general practice
vaccination by the first of december
that doesn't mean that the vaccine will
be available from the first of december
necessarily
um but that we need to be prepared to
have
um those sites nominated and staff ready
to be trained so there's a training
program that's available
nationally and the specification hasn't
yet been finalized we're expecting that
by the end of this week
together with some further operational
details about um
about the trading and about how vac how
to vaccinate um there is payment
attached
um so the um the general practitioners
um get an item of service fee which is
to deliver the vaccination
and there is also you might have heard
there is um a national announcement
of a further 150 million nationally
to support general practice that isn't
to deliver the vaccine but it is to help
with things like workforce and backfill
so that
normal unusual core general practice
business can still be delivered because
it's really important
that we don't lose sight of the fact
that general practice is open as usual
and the vaccine is is an add-on to that
so that's what's been made available
nationally
um in terms of where things are up to
we've been working really hard because
the deadline to submit the designated
sites is tomorrow as usual with these
things we don't get a lot of time
so we've been actively engaged with our
primary care networks
and and we've had confirmation from four
out of the five that they will sign up
to the specification
they feel they are indeed the right
people to be delivering this based on
our experiences of the flu vaccine
and the kind of knowledge of the
patients the identification of the
patients and the fact that they're able
to
educate and gain consent to deliver the
vaccine so we've had positive sign up
from
four out of the five hopefully get the
fifth one um engaged today
so um it's we're on track um
i met with manchester college on friday
because where possible
we're going to adopt a program
management approach in
partnership with uh manchester to to get
this up and running and do what we can
that makes sense
um to do jointly and that we've got the
right governance in place as well so
that we're feeding into the
into the right um forums in terms of
escalation risks and challenges
and we've just received over the weekend
a stakeholder briefing as well on the
vaccination program so i will make sure
that that's available to you all as well
because that's um provides more helpful
detail um and i'll pause there any
questions
thanks rebecca i think that that issue
of capacity is really interesting within
um gp practice and actually it's a
similar challenge that we're going to
face with the mass testing stuff around
you know test 10 percent of your
population we will give you the
resources to do that but not necessarily
the people because obviously local
governments in general practice
aren't at all busy at the moment so it
is um
it is a it is a similar challenge across
the piece and it is
concerning me quite significantly at the
moment but i don't know if anybody
um wanted to to come in on this if you
pop in the chat if you'd like to come in
[Music]
no okay no problem thank you for that
rebecca if we move on um then
to 5c which is the covert engagement
coordination group um update and
escalations which is the two helens i
think helen grant and helen collins
please all right i'm gonna hand over to
laura hobbs if that's all right
um i think that's you helen
collins but i can't hear you very well
sorry i can say i'm just gonna hand over
to
laura hobbs she's been a bit all right
okay bro hi laura
um yeah so just a bit of an update from
the uh coordination group
so uh the teams have been working hard
to reflect on the kind of the new
lockdown
restrictions um and sort of understand
what that means there obviously was some
elements of kind of ambiguity in that
and it's not quite the kind of the full
lockdown that we had back in march and
april
um so we've had various different uh
stakeholder briefings that have gone out
to businesses and communities to try and
explain what this kind of lockdown looks
and feels like and how there is some
differences
um i think things like the trafford
center are obviously still running
um and there are click and collect
services still available for
um four businesses uh so we've got i
think maybe 28 shops in the trafford
center still open
and i think that there's eight um that
are fully open so boots and super drug
and things like that
so we're kind of trying to think about
how we manage that slightly differently
because of course instead of people
going
into shops we've got kind of people
waiting outside and clustering outside
so it's our environmental health team
have been very much kind of working with
the trafford centre to make sure that
we've got face coverings and compliance
um with the kind of good practice
covered rules
our parks and play areas are still open
and
so the team have increased signage
across
those open spaces um kind of distance
hand
face space those kind of messages as
well
um in relation to bonfire night
um we disseminated lots of messaging out
in in order to
kind of reinforce that they weren't
allowed to do um displays
uh there was lots of reports around kind
of younger people in
in parks setting on fireworks so we're
just kind of reflecting on that and
trying to think about how
um we engage with sort of parents um
and others to sort of make sure that
that we we know that there's going to be
an increase in kind of gatherings in
parks and house parties over the next
period because
obviously people aren't allowed um out
in the same way so it's just thinking
about how we engage
with parents kind of know where your
kids are kind of campaigns
we're still very much connected to our
faith leaders
and they're continuing to work hard to
sort of disseminate messages within
congregations obviously we don't have
congregations happening at the moment so
it's about that kind of connectivity and
making sure that
we're still engaging through whatsapp
messaging
radio systems i know a lot of the faith
leaders have kind of used volunteers
and it's about kind of using them again
to keep everybody
informed up to date um
our public health team are working hard
as ever and i'm sure helen can give a
bit of an update but
they have developed some information for
um
children's and families and other other
teams within the council
about how we kind of make sure every
contact counts so we've got huge
workforce within the council
two and a half thousand people so it's
really about you know
making sure that every opportunity we
have to engage with people we're kind of
leveraging that we've got clarity about
what the rules mean
um and we can and we can make sure that
we kind of capitalize on on those
opportunities i know eleanor and mark
jarvis ran
a q a facebook live event
um and took lots of questions from the
public
um and that was well attended um and i
know helen and the team are working
really really hard as well with um
schools and education um partners to
make sure that again we kind of leverage
the
the school support and the contact
tracing
um and there's there's kind of really
really good ways of working
with that sector lots of information
going on schools schools
websites um i guess
from from our perspective it's an ask
for you really um
in terms of what do what what what more
can we do
so i know uh the partnerships team have
been successful in getting some sort of
lottery funding
um so they are recruiting some hub
coordinators and we're going to link him
with lots of volunteers to try and kind
of strengthen our engagement activity
um i think there is some data to sort of
suggest that there's a bit more apathy
with with this lockdown
um and you know so so people's kind of
willingness to lock down is slightly
different
um and of course you know people's
thoughts and feelings do
affect their behavior so i think from
our perspective it's really about trying
to understand
um you know how do we do a good job or a
better job
at understanding what the barriers might
be and connecting with various different
communities to make sure that that we
kind of use this opportunity that we've
got in lockdown
to to lock down and to bring those those
numbers down so that hopefully we can
have a christmas
thanks laura dorothy will you indicate
that
it's just that um over the last week or
so
last week i think there's been um
guidance
on um vulnerable people and that's
people with learning disabilities
who are deemed to be six times more
likely now
um to catch covid and one of the things
that i've seen
is easy read material that's going out
to those
communities that explains what they
should be doing i'm just wondering if
we're doing that in trafford
because not only will that have an
impact on um
the person it will also have an impact
on carers
and also on their caring functions etc
and i'm just wondering what we're doing
to
reassure people about um
that that report that's just come out
so i don't know if um laura or indeed
anybody else knows the specific answer
to that but i'd make a plea that if we
aren't
doing that um we look to emulate that as
quickly as possible
i don't know dorothy if you've got um a
link to any examples of that that you
could share with us that would be really
helpful if you have
um but i'll send send something across
well sorry laura did you want to come in
on that i mean just just to say
i mean we're looking at kind of
accessibility to information
um across the piste really so we're
doing a whole um redesign of
our kind of covered landing page um
we're looking at our video messaging so
um there is some videos at the moment
that that are accessible
um the team have just i think bought
some new um
videoing equipment so we're kind of
creating a bit of a priority list in
terms of
what what the key videos the gaps are
and all the materials that we've got so
we can certainly have a look at ld
materials and make sure that
that you know if there is a gap there we
fill it
thank you eleanor were you looking to
come in yeah just that we we had used
some materials earlier on in
um the pandemics so i think we need to
just review the materials that have been
used and make sure that they're still
um accurate and so on and get those out
because um dorothy is quite right our
learning disabled population is one that
we really do want to make sure
we get that reach to both people living
and supported living accommodation but
also people living
um at home and with their families so it
is a really important
group of people to reach
yeah okay thank you um anything from
from anybody else on
on this one
joe do you want to actually i think it
would be helpful if you want to come in
and just give a
an update on clinically extremely
vulnerable i guess now
as appropriate time as anything okay
yeah i suppose it's a round sort of com
so just to report that
i mean the government have obviously
written to everybody who are on the
clinically extremely vulnerable list
that's around about 9 100 households in
trafford
and we have actually followed up with a
specific letter to all the residents in
trafford
as well describing or asking people to
register
their needs on the national shielding
support system
which is where we can they can answer
some questions and we can pick up
whether they need
any more specific support and we're
doing some outbound calling
um on those individuals so we've
contacted all clinically extremely
vulnerable in trafford that's around
about 9100
people and so far i think as out
thursday last week
we'd had around 152 registrations on
that system
and done 33 calls back to people to
understand their support needs
you can also register for priority
supermarket slots on that
system and there's around about 80
people that have registered for those
so that's kind of our proactive
um outbound sort of communications to
people on that list we've also just to
let everybody know that obviously
the um coded response the community hubs
are still up and running that model is
still out there
we're still using the o 300 number in
order to direct people through that
if they do want support as well um so
that they can have
a conversation with somebody on the end
of that telephone number
and where necessary will be put through
to the community hubs for further
um assessment and and support as
as needed around things like food access
to food
um the sort of social isolation offer
um being able to connect digitally and
general sort of well-being as well
okay there's no actual massive spike in
demand on that number at the moment but
it
is still there and you know we're ready
to
support people as as when we hear from
them that's great
thanks joe um any any questions for joe
on that on that
um offer to the people that were not
allowed to fail shielding
no no okay that's great well thank you
um for that update laura was there
anything else on
um on that on the substantive item
before we move on to
the health and social care steering
group update
i think we've got um helen grant was
going to give a bit of an update from an
enforcement perspective
hi helen hi i'm just trying to get my
camera working
um yeah just um an update on the
um enforcement group and so this was
established and when we first went into
lockdown and became less frequent as we
came
out of lockdown and now we've kind of
had further restrictions it's been
stepped back
up to a weekly group so that's attended
by
community safety greater manchester
police environmental health
um licensing and
also um our main housing provider
operational group so each week we kind
of bring where we're
up to in terms of action and enforcement
just to coordinate activity and to make
sure that we're not all
as agencies focusing on you know certain
addresses whilst missing others
and what we do in community safety is
look at the residential
addresses so for example if there's a
huge kind of house party going on gmp
will probably attend
that and if there are kind of flagrant
breaches may issue a fixed penalty
notice it
for the ones where perhaps it's you know
reports they've just kind of covered
breaches somebody's got another
household coming round or it's a
retrospective report
then community safety picked those up in
terms of a staged
procedure so the gm compliance cell kind
of um
put together a process and some template
documents which we've just adapted
the trafford to do that what i would say
is that earlier in the year when we're
in the first lockdown we were getting
lots and lots of reports and from
neighbours just reporting covered
breaches
what we're seeing more of now and i'd
say around 70
of the reports that we get are ones
where there are other antisocial
behavior elements to it
so there might be kind of noise or you
know allegations of smoking drugs and
things like that so it's
it's the things that are impacting our
neighbors more that they are reporting
to us
um obviously environmental health attend
that meeting and
also licensing so they work you know in
an aligned way with gmp
to address any kind of businesses or
licensed premises that that might be
breaching
i think it's possibly because the
lockdown is is more kind of
restrictive at the moment it's probably
easier in some ways for people to
understand
what what the kind of rules are around
that and but they're certainly joined up
in terms of you know they've been
attending the
trafford center on a weekend we've also
got the
um contract that's being renewed with
the information offices so whilst they
don't have
enforcement powers they are covered
information officers
and that we can direct to certain
locations where we think people might
need
advice around and covered security and
breaches and then just planning where we
think
there might be potential issues so there
were some concerns around remembering
some day that lots and lots of people
might turn up and not be socially
distancing so
and we had people at some of those
venues you know and and people were were
very complain and you know
mostly stayed away and paid respects on
their doorsteps but
a few people came down to some of the
kind of war memorials and senators but
in a socially distanced way in their
household groups and bubbles
so the um enforcement meeting is held
every
monday afternoon so given an update this
is kind of retrospective of where we
were
last monday um but that helps us to kind
of then plan for the week ahead in terms
of directing activity
of our staff so that's kind of where
we're up to if anybody's got any
questions around that
thanks helen i imagine you will be
having a very interesting conversation
about sale makers market
this afternoon i've seen an email
yeah but i won't i won't dwell on that
for now um
i'll pick that up outside of the uh
outside of the meeting but are there any
um questions or comments from people
on um the enforcement side of the work
that we're doing obviously
you'll have seen um throughout the week
that we have taken action on the on the
business side
unfortunately where people are not
following um
the guidance and rules around that and
if you know if people
um are doing that then it is important
out of fairness that for all businesses
really don't
mean to do that as well as the obvious
um health reasons why
we're all doing it in the first place um
don't know if there
doesn't seem to be anybody that's
waiting to come in on that
no okay so if we
um if we move on to the
next item which is the health and social
care steering group update and
escalations tracy are you
um giving us that update please yes i am
thank you
um so the meeting actually only meets
monthly so there isn't much progression
but one key thing that we will be doing
over the next week is around manchester
foundation trust
and they've recently um shared developed
some
frequently asked questions for their
patients around the pausing of elective
care
and so therefore what we need to do is
work as partners to try and raise that
as much as possible i think that's some
key learning from ourselves
around this and i think many of us in
this meeting today
will have heard about people really
feeling when and the pandemic first
started
that patients were done to and were not
really informed so
we need to learn from that and ensure
that we we share those messages
and as fully as possible also and
manchester foundation trust have also
written to patients so those patients
who
were going to be having elective care
that they
are now going to receive a letter around
that as well to provide more information
about what's going on
and we've also advised our gp's as well
so they know in case they get
that message and in terms of um the
other thing as well it is
self-care week this week and public
engagement board of the last
um meeting um actually said that they
would help to support
self-care week because of course it's a
really challenging time for everybody
who works in health and social care and
actually anyone who's working so um
there has been hopefully
fabiola was able to share with you a
constant engagement plan which the
steering group have developed
and with some key messages around there
if that hasn't fabiola if you can do
that today that would be great
um or if you actually see the the
council or the ccgs
and tweets each day that we're just
really
trying to prioritize some some key
messages for both our workforce
and for members of the public as well so
thank you very much
thanks um tracy that's really useful and
fabiola has sent that round but he's
offering to do so again which
which is helpful thank you um are there
any questions or comments
on um this for tracy at all
no okay that's great thank you very much
for that
one um and if we then move on to um
the age well board update and
escalations
i'm not sure who is taking us through
this i thought it was maybe
um so it's a fairly brief update from me
this morning the age well board is
actually meeting on thursday so it's a
great opportunity if anyone
you know has any questions or you know
anything
that um i can take forward to that
meeting on thursday
so we have now developed a role
description for our older people's voice
which will hopefully be signing off on
thursday
and i think that's going to be a really
important role in terms of
raising awareness helping to spread key
messages across the borough
um we're also working with partners to
complete a self-audit to look at
how we can be supporting residents over
this challenging winter period
and that covers four main aspects which
is physical conditioning
mental well-being social isolation and
financial well-being
so again that's looking at how we're
sort of contributing
to the gm priorities and
we are also linking with gm colleagues
to arrange for the distribution of 12
000 copies
of the keeping well this winter booklet
so
that's hopefully going to be um also
working through the hubs as well
so a fairly brief update but i should
hopefully have more after the the next
stage while board on thursday
that's great thank you um louise any
any questions or comments um
on that at all
no no
okay well thank you louise that's um
takes us through the updates the various
updates on the ten point plan
um the next item and indeed really the
following one or just around
the work of the board anything that
people thinks that think that the
um the board should be looking at and
any anything that people want to
escalate really and i suppose i'm going
to go first with this and the review
um times on the agenda where i could
have raised this
um and i want to do it in this public
forum not that i think anybody on this
call has
um an immediate answer but we talked
about
um well testing and vaccinations and the
focus on care homes we talked about the
age well board
but we still have this significant issue
with family members not being able to
safely visit
um care home residents and i think in
the run-up to christmas
we are going to see even more
of a kickback on this and i recognized
that um
gm submitted a paper some time ago
actually i've been uh
mothering diane about this for a while
now um but it is
you know in many ways it's a it's a
difficult balance between
um safety and the mental health and
well-being of care home patients and
their families but i i really
just wanted an update because i know
that the last time
um that that i had an update on this was
that gm had come up with a fairly
restrictive
um way in which visits could be enabled
but that we were waiting for um approval
from government
on that um but it is it is a little
while ago and i know that this is a
public forum and i wanted to just ask
where we were at for that and whether
there is any hope that we can give to
people who are in that position because
increasingly you know the correspondence
that i receive is quite heartbreaking on
that so i don't know
perhaps ask diane if there is anything
on that just just initially
yes thank you councillor weston i am i
have good news
that there there's been some new
guidance issued which eleanor and team
have reviewed
and we've written to the care homes
asking them to complete an individual
risk assessment by home
and to commence visiting in a either
window visiting with a shield garden
pods that a lot of them have
um had fitted or in a room that has an
outside access
doorway so that they can then screen off
that room but
visitors can come in from the outside
there is a lot of cleaning requirements
for them obviously between visits
and but we have advised them they can
commence visits once that work is
is done and if they need any advice or
guidance we're here to
support um either through our
commissioning team or through our public
health team
so there is hope we will get people
visiting before christmas which i am
very
very happy about as i know you are
that's great thanks diane so just to
just to clarify that work won't
won't be completed before the 2nd of
december presumably
some homes it may be if the pods are
already in
if the pod is not fitted or the or the
solution isn't ready then it may take
slightly longer so every home
obviously slightly different depending
on the layout of the home et cetera that
the
ellen has just confirmed in the chat
that the letter went
out to the homes on the 6th of november
so
and they are they're commencing that
work but a lot of them have been working
this ought to be readiness for the day
that they get
agreement to visit oh that's that's
that's great news and i know that'll
come as a relief to a lot of um
a lot of families i suppose the question
then is just for us to
um try and keep an eye on those homes
who can't accommodate
visits because they don't either have
the secure room or the garden part and
um you know just to see if there's
anything that we can do i
i mean it sounds as though the window
visit may still remain an option
um but if we've got anywhere where none
of them are um
just just to see what support we can
provide to families and residents
absolutely we will do that we'll track
in the the completion of the work every
two days um in in the week so
we'll uh feedback on any that we're
struggling with but we'll help them with
solutions
right yeah fine oh yeah no come in sorry
i'm waving
yeah um i think the the window visit is
quite uh
appropriate if it is possible uh but of
course we had a
not long ago we had a case of a blind
person
could not actually visit his wife who
was blind as well
so i think we need to look at that if if
we got cases like that
how do we actually enable
visits to take place
yeah um eleanor
one of the things we're looking at is
how we can use now we've got more
testing how we can um involve uh
people regular visitors to care homes in
a in a
regular testing program as the care home
staff are so that's something we're
looking at as well
um it's we had the slight complexity
with the
the way the math the um the lateral flow
test
has to be delivered means that it's not
quite as it's straightforward as we
thought it might be but we are looking
at how we can get people
who um who want to be regular visitors
um how we can get them regularly tested
so that's very much something we're
looking at for precisely those
situations
yeah and all the way through of course
um we have been able to maintain visits
for
exceptional circumstances which tends to
be very sadly end of life
um so the difficult one of the
difficulties we have at the moment is
that the number of
um care homes with k active cases are
covered within the home
has gone up quite a bit and obviously
that would again you wouldn't want a
visitor going into those home because of
the risk
for them um as well as the risks they
bring in
um so this is something that we're
really trying to to get on top of and
again it yeah
it comes back to the the general high
levels of code
in the community while we've got that
level
of community transmission it is very
very difficult to keep it out of the
care homes
despite the enormous efforts that care
home staff
are taking to do that um so we have seen
as i say quite a few homes without
breaks despite you know really really um
very very hard work on part of the staff
and managers of the homes
thanks eleanor and i i mean i heard that
call into andy burnham's radio burning
from the
um from the gentleman that had lost his
wife where both of them were blind and
it was incredibly sad so we do need to
um you know make sure that we're doing
everything with everything that we can
and but that actually sounds um
incredibly promising and and
um really good news so i'm glad that i
raised it in a public forum actually
um was there anything else that people
wanted to
raise either around the work that the
board is doing
um or or not doing if there's things
that you think that we should be taking
forward or that you just wanted to
raise or escalate to the board at all
elena i just wanted to say that we are
um
we'll be hoping to get some named
individuals leading for each
of the neighborhoods of trafford so
north south
uh western central um and
i know that once those people have been
identified one of the first things i
want to do is
speak to members of the board um
individually or as a group or probably
both to try and make sure that they get
the insights from
board members of how to focus the work
and how to progress that
thanks eleanor i'm not seeing any
indications from
anybody else so is there any other
business that anybody wanted to
um to raise at all
no okay well i'm going to i'm going to
sum the meeting up as as tentatively
positive with numbers coming down with
plans for mass vaccination coming
forward and with care home visits
potentially looking
possible safely in the next few weeks so
um
you know hopefully fingers crossed we'll
have even better news in a couple of
weeks time but in the meantime
um i'll draw the meeting to a close and
just hope everybody stays safe and thank
you for all that
that you're doing to to support
residents at the moment thanks everybody
thank you